Speaker 1: I want to play for you.
A fascinating video of the Ukrainian President
Volodymyr Zelensky spoke yesterday via satellite
uplink or maybe over the internet, via teleconference
with or to British Parliament, and received
a standing ovation.
And we're going to just kind of catch up on
a few of the different things that took place
over the last 24 hours.
Here is the Russian president, the Ukrainian
president, rather addressing you, British
parliament, about the Russian invasion of
his country, Ukraine.
Speaker 2: Well, we are looking at his agency
for your help, for the help of the civilized
countries.
We are we are thankful for this help and we
are grateful to be objectionable, Boris.
And I'm very grateful to you, Boris.
We'll see you decency.
Please increase the pressure of sanctions
against this country and please recognize
this country as a terrorist state.
And please make sure that our Ukrainian skies
are safe for you.
Please make sure that you do what needs to
be done and what is stipulated by the greatness
of your country, Ukraine, blah blah blah.
Keep it back.
Best of all, to Ukraine and to the United
Kingdom.
Speaker 1: It's truly remarkable that a president
who by all accounts and I'm talking about
Zelensky here was sort of OK, you know, before
this and not particularly well-liked has rapidly
become a hero not only within Ukraine but
internationally.
And we can debate whether in the totality
of what is Zelensky's legacy, that makes sense.
It is not really the debate for today because
it is what is happening, being being held
up as a hero.
And I mean, listen, when you look at what
he's doing, he every opportunity to have left
and so many other things that that he chose
to do, which he didn't have to.
I understand why this is the reaction, regardless
of what our thoughts about Zelensky would
have been even as recently as six weeks ago.
Now what is happening in the Russian invasion
of Ukraine?
We are learning about yet another one of these
columns of armored vehicles and tanks pushing
further into Ukraine.
We are learning about the refugee crisis of
individuals leaving Ukraine many as quickly
as they possibly can on trains, even walking
over the border.
I was watching, as I often do Argentinean
news, and Argentina has reporters on the Ukrainian
Polish border.
And I mean, just children walking across the
border.
Truly heartbreaking images in terms of the
economic sanctions.